chris woodward has been suspended for
today's game he will not be managing the
rangers ian jabo is out for three games
although he will appeal his suspension
major league baseball was swift in
punishing the rangers for what they
deemed unnecessary retaliation
apparently that's a man on four tattoos
two home runs last night here's 10th and
11th and the ground ball sharply that is
a base hit to left field so no pitches
close to tatis good sign
he's got a base hit so after three
straight singles mike miner has a chance
to get out of this mess if he can get
will myers
in play high fly ball deep to left
center field
car rushed
while going ball long gone will myers
tati
yesterday late myers early today they
say the ball's not flying there it's
flying with exit velocity and a swing
like that by will myers his sixth home
run of the season it's a grand slam the
boys lead by four-nothing
third grand slam of the season for the
padres second in his many games
and boy do they need that
gallo one for two last night with an rbi
and a couple of walks he's hitting 212
five homers 12 rbis this ball swung on
and lifted
down the right field line that one is
over the shoulder catch made down the
right field line how about that play
all the way down in the corner
manny the magician how does he catch
this ball the flash look
oh my goodness and the lead off man
aboard here in the top of the fourth
inning for the padres so here's jerks
and profile this one is in the air to
left field down the line towards the
corner and the pole and that ball is
gone
a two-run home run for jericho pro fires
third into padres uniform and the padres
jump out to a six-nothing lead in texas
he's starting to pick it up offensively
last couple of games and here's a two
run shot for jericho pro far the former
texas ranger osmer up with machado on
first tatis on second and tatis breaks
for third jabot sees it fires to frazier
and apparently frazier missed the tag
but frazier's running off the field
confident that he got him
oh yeah tough to tell i think he might
have gotten his
right leg he definitely had appeared
missed the body and the rangers are
asking for a review todd is so confident
that
he got him he's already in the dugout
hat off he is safe so it was not clear
and convincing and tatis with his sixth
stolen base of the year so here's guerra
with two on and nobody out gallow the
battle swinging a high fly ball hit to
center grisham going back at the track
at the wall he leaps and that one is out
of here
a three-run home run to straight away
center field for joey gallo
just beyond the leap
of trent grisham and gallows sixth home
run of the season cuts the rangers
deficit in half it's now six to three
eight him at the dish over one he struck
out swinging against mori home to lead
off
serena ball hit hard on the ground past
the guy but machado down the left road
now gets a base hit and rolling to the
corner solace scores from third
heinemann to second takes a big turn as
his helmet falls off but the relay from
profile is cut off by tatis and
heinemann stays put
but it's an rbi double for scott
heinemann as he snaps out of an o for
10.
the rangers add another as they cut the
deficit to two it's now six to four the
bases are loaded on three walks and with
two outs in the inning trent grisham's
coming out and there's a swing and a
slow ground ball on the right side
charged by the kick flip on the first
and the inning is over nice job by
rodriguez no runs no hits they leave him
loaded
santana has struck you out and singled
this one smacked on the right side great
diving stop at second base by
crowdenberg makes the throw from his
knees and got him jake cronin where you
see him in the upper right hand corner
good first step diving
from his knees jake do you see the light
putting the band back together nice play
solace at third d trick at second
heinemann at first six four pages in the
air harmlessly will myers is coming in
camping out calling catching that is all
for trevino tying run to come to the
plate for the rangers here in the eighth
and here's derek dietrich and a high fly
ball out to deep right field myers is
there has a little room just in front of
the warning track he makes the catch
dietrich gave it a ride but not in this
park six to four the padres have a lead
over the rangers it is emilia pagan who
is back out there to begin the bottom of
the ninth inning
as he does cal quantrill
and matt strong continue to warm in the
padres bullpen or two outs
in the air to center field grisham is
under it grisham will make the catch and
the padres hold on to win